[Musique]
ils iront secret de la vie si tout mon
corps est astucieux bellemène et la
jolie mais aussi le plus sérieux n'avait
pas joué il suffit de vouloir devenir un
ami
et voilà le tchad toi tu sais j à la
note pas où tu très bien la note
bonjour fabrice bonjour tout cas encore
bonjour à tous et à toutes
toi tu vas bonjour à tous et à toutes
une forme olympique
c'est par disons mais les payes ta
chemise la magnifique je peux
m'approcher va vivre on regarde quel
sens à ta des boutons à figer des
boutons en général au suisse j'ai plutôt
des boutons gleadow tu sais maman elle
avoir une une comme ça oui
eh ben on va voir ça la prochaine fois
peut-être peut-être je vais essayer un
tu prends la petite taille une petite
taille
ouais moi parfait bonjour je mène alors
le jeu d'ajouter intelligent à dire ça
je suis bien alors c'est à dire par
donald rheault qui va trouver la cape
d'un pays à deviner bon alors tout le
monde devine avait avec nous tout le
monde peut deviner
bon faut chercher parce que n est pas
toujours facile à ce que si on ne trouve
pas des tartes - j'ai des réserves
il ya le drapeau après voilà voilà la
carte du pays c'est pas la nièvre à nous
pas vraiment non les 3l et la capitale
et là on regarde le drapeau du pays a
pas tout de suite par luan qui peut de
la capitale qui est place est là comme
un grain de bouderbala capitale la
capitale est très haute
abu el et à une certaine altitude déjà
et ça n'est pas très facile de respirer
quand on n'est pas habitué à cette
altitude moi ça pour aimer souffler il
est possible que ça s'essouffle un peu
winamax est une capitale intéressante il
ya des tas de choses formidables autour
on va voir le drapeau aux standards pays
voici le drapeau du pays il va te plaire
celui-là arabe bombarde ici pourquoi
oui parce qu'il a un motif il est un
motif au centre c'est le même drapeau
que le drapeau italien à peu de choses
près à part évidemment le motif qui est
au centre en effet vous avez là les
bandes verticales vers blanche et rouge
pourquoi blanche bas parce que c'est la
couleur au centre vers le drapeau blanc
et la couleur luis et les bandes qui
sans verte blanche et rouge voit plus et
au centre il ya un motif avec un aigle
qui apparemment un serpent dans la
dans le bec oui les aigles mois puis cei
a un qui nous permet à mais un peu jeune
alors comment dit-on bonjour dans ce
pays on dit buenos dias un one hausse
des seniors
on l'a déjà dit oui parce que c'est un
pays qui parle espagnol et il ya
beaucoup de pays qui parlent espagnol
qu'est ce que tu me disais je te dis que
c'est le mexique mais non c'est pas ça
tu me disais buenos dias seniors cabaye
c'est le mexique avec sa capitale mexico
ici les ducs l'airé de repos et il dit
qu'est ce qui a je ne peux pas monter la
note
mais avant ça l'important buenos dias et
on peut dire aussi quand on s'en va a
dit en jeu tout con carne a dit johan
guillou la gauche radicale et ils se
doutent pas il se doute pas de ce qu'il
est
et vous savez où il est parti maintenant
il est réglé comme du papier à musique
alors c'est le point commun
nous avons choisi la fête oui bien sûr
j'ignore si c'est si si tu vois je
continue à parler espagnol as les faits
celle-ci non pour se suicider
qu'est ce que c'est que ça en corse et
quelle langue ça tu vas me dire ça ici
alors tous qu encore le point commun
c'est ça
nous rappelons brièvement oui rapidos ya
quelque chose qui va pas non je peux
participer au point com - si tu es
sérieux et si tu restes là d'accord très
bien
je veux juste sorti de ma coquille oui
date jimenez suis là mais non t'énerve
pas tout quand elle en voyant offrir
hier pas tout cas encore oui aujourd'hui
nous écoutons tu es quoi je suis
dangereux
ah bon oui je suis très dangereux
heureusement ma main et beaucoup de gens
de rentrer c'est moins grave mais alors
cet été sur les plats vocaux j'étais
dangereux l'été prochain aussi je le
serai ou au moment de la baignade
il faut regarder la couleur du drapeau
ainsi lettres oranges ou rouges c'est à
dire si la mer est dangereuse ça veut
dire que je ne suis pas loin
vous ne pouvez pas me voir ou alors
quand quand vous me voyez
il est trop tard je suis une sorte de
grosse vague qui gonfle qui gonfle et
qui emporte tout sur son passage
voilà alors est un oui c'était très
clair c'est clair valbelle alors moi je
suis très utilisé par les femmes surtout
par les femmes qui s'occupent beaucoup
de leur intérieur ce qui est mon cas
vous savez que pour être une maîtresse
de maison accompli il faut savoir faire
beaucoup de choses entre autres la
cuisine et tout spécialement la
pâtisserie et c'est là que je suis très
utile car si je n'existais pas je
voudrais bien savoir comment on
arriverait à les faire c'est partout
pommes aux fraises aux mirabelles et ce
gâteau roulé au chocolat et ses
délicieux feuilleter fourrés de patte
d'un mois de confusion ou fabrice alors
là je m'arrête là sinon je vais me
précipite chez le pâtissier moi aussi
moi c'est parce que j'ai toujours faim
oui je ne digère pas les talk mois non
non ça ne fait rien tu n'en auras pas
comme ça ça ira table bon alors moi
aussi moi je suis quelque chose qui fait
très très peur pour leur art c'est gros
c'est lourd c'est très impressionnant et
ça se promènent lentement sur les routes
mais l'horreur on voit tout de suite que
ça n'a peur de rien ça écrase tout sur
son passage
tu pensais pour moi si c'est si c'est
dangereux tu te rends compte
mais il paraît que c'est très utile pour
construire les routes pour éviter qu'il
y ait des bosses moi je veux bien mais
il ya une chose certaine c'est que c'est
pas drôle du tout de se trouver nez à
nez avec un engin pareil moi je te le
dira j'espère que tu as trouvé est bien
bien bien je crois que je commence à
avoir une idée assez précise de soins
beer vrai c'est bien vrai bah oui tu as
trouvé toi oui bah oui bon et là c'est
quoi qui vous avez besoin d'être vous
pouvez de mort je te demande c'est quoi
le point commun qui unit tous cambell
belle épouse michelle peut le dire
10 le boulot mais c'est formidable
il est extraordinaire mais bravo en
effet même si en effet tout quand elle
était un rouleau de la mer mais ce passé
roule aussi dangereux dont il faut se
méfier mais elle belle était le rouleau
à pâtisserie
et oui dont il faut se méfier et quand
on les marie et qu'on rentre trop tard
le soir et aux siens et puis enfin
pouces moussu était le rouleau que l'on
voit sur les routes lorsqu on penche sur
les routes le rouleau qui égalise l'as
valour compresse le rouleau compresseur
a salué un bon ami comme ça aux pauvres
c'est moche ça monsieur sur une route
secondaire
c'était à ne nous raconte pas des
histoires aussi triste au rapid normal
c'est beaucoup trop triste et moi je
vais essayer d'égayer tout le monde et
fabrice en particulier en lui préparant
notre petit jeu musical et oui les
sétois a détruit aux rebelles
bon alors à brienz foule su mais il est
à toi c'est à nous maintenant
bon alors tu vas au tableau oui je ne te
demande pas si tu as fait des projets en
leur temps parce que je sais que ces
noms là je je je n'ose pas je n'ose pas
te dire oui je n'ose va te dire non mais
j'ai travaillé cette semaine je
travaillais pouvais j'ai trouvé ça
toutes les semaines avec le mon ami tout
cancan hé bien moi je veux bien
alors tu vas au tableau oui alors cette
semaine un mot en cette lettre à la
première la première 1p à la 1 2 3 4 5
et la dernière est la dernière et accent
aigu et accent aigu voilà alors la c1
qu'est ce que ça peut être que c'est un
animal ray non c'est pas un ami cette
fois ci c'est pas un animal une plante
elle ne dit pas exactement une plante
instruits non non c'est pas un fruit un
légume non plus une fleur un arbre eh
ben c'est un arbre un hard à trouver
un grand arbre ah oui ah oui assez oh
oui veux-tu une petite led supprimer ce
que je vais te dire je suis pas très
calé dans le valeurs la quatrième lettre
la quatrième c1 paix a aussi un p voilà
ap un arm 1p y en a beaucoup sur le bord
des routes
c'est à dire c'est pour un platane sur
le bord des routes nationales où l'art
secondaire oulala il y en a pas sur
l'autoroute wali lalalalalala apte à
trouver je crois mais j'en vois aussi
l'erreur colossal que tu encore commises
au corps peupliers pas possible publiez
vos billets bravo tu as trouvé alors les
peupliers et leur peupliers se termine
d'après toi par et accent aigu ah oui
telus t elle y est accent aigu pour
habiller de kankan tu décris comme ça
également le yvias a atteint je crois
que nous avons une grosse île près
d'hirak ces deux là on n'est pas sorti
de la fenêtre une façon différente
donc oui ça il ya une façon différente
ya la bonne façon d'écrire peupliers pe
u plj eu là nous sommes d'accord il faut
un air à la fin air à la fois la
peupliers avec un air à l'affiché pas
possible c'est très bien il ya trop de
choses à apprendre sans espoir cette
histoire l'an enfin moi je vais
peut-être apprendre quelque chose quoi
on trouve souvent des espèces de boue de
coton sur les peupliers cliché s'est
collé au au grain et à un moment ça
tombe par terre
eh bien il faut faire très attention que
les animaux ne les mangent pas surtout
surtout les moutons à il pourrait en
mourir
ah je ne savais pas sa fabrication alors
qu'on a eu on mange des choses et bah
oui faut faire très attention
babri puis c'est que c'est intéressant
est ce que tu viennes bachy mais jose
alors trouvez vous nous allons relever
la factrice qui a joué avec moi là c'est
facile la musique le 20 janvier en bois
domine tellement c'est ça va bosser
bella taylor fabrice oui je te raconte
une histoire
moi je joue avec les neuf les bruits et
tu complète par les notes de musique les
mots que je vais laisser inachevé et
alors l'europe
oui et elle a fait toutes les notes que
tu rappes la cites donneront l'air d'une
chanson très connue mais de lunettes
maintenant mais quoi tu ne savais pas
non jamais jamais vu les six jeux pour
femmes je mets ça par coquetterie ça
c'est pas du tout parce que j'ai les
yeux annoncé alors c'est une chose au
plein air dont tu vas deviner les
premières notes d'une chanson pour tous
ceux qui aiment la nature les travaux
des champs ce qu'aime bêcher piocher la
boot et la bourrée labouré ray ray
embargo et surtout ceux qui aiment semer
car c'est important de semer si on veut
qualité récolte peut être en plus c'est
excellent pour la santé de faire tous
ces travaux des champs ça vaut toutes
les gymnastiques on se dépense on se
remplit pour mon dos quand j'aime ces
jeunes donc si j'allais quand on est
fatigué on va s'allonger suzanne arbres
crois moi c'est aussi bon de faire de la
boucle est de l'habitacle est de la
bicyclette encore assez bien sûr voilà
ces travaux demandent une certaine
technique il faut savoir se servir d'une
belge d'une frange de râteaux enfin il
ne faut pas être ma droit maladroit
alors si tu veux je t'apprends vrai je
le donnerai quelques conseils et ibera
qui me remettre la cie va d'abord tu
auras appris quelque chose planter des
carottes des choux des salades et
ensuite tu te sentir en pleine forme
pour venir nous retrouver la semaine
prochaine alors tu lapointe c'est prêt
uch yon c'est une rétribution à ré
solution
il est né voilà rés
ainsi si la 610 ses chiens eh ben je ne
sais pas moi c'est nabi
[Musique]
vous vous foutez là c'est ça eh bien
c'était pas tant fabrice et maintenant
nous allons chanter notre petit coeur en
son genre et avec nos petits camarades
voilà voilà déjà pape a commis deux
tacles à peu près que la vie s'est
désisté et g shock sa défense mais comme
je ne nie pas de baignoire mais pour
rappel
attention les canaris sont traqués sans
répit et y'a qu'ça ni sont heureux
d'arriver à billets
oui
oh
alors
me ravit pas joué aujourd'hui et je vis
à vis de vouloir devenir amis
harry
m
gardiens
[Musique]